and we've had the talk that the majority
of women today do not deserve chivalry a
woman that is ungrateful for chivalry
does not deserve it and it there used to
be a time where men would actually get
something in return for chivalry they
would get a pure wife they would get a
wife that was in shape and they would
get a wife that respects and honors them
and that was the cultural norm but now
the cultural norm is you can't tell me
anything I'll do what I want and nobody
can tell me I'm wrong so Bill bur I
don't know much about B bur I honestly
have not followed
his life I've not followed his comedy I
don't I don't know much about him I'm
I'm G to preface with this but I saw a
video of him going viral of his wife
actually flipping off Donald Trump I'm
going to come back later but I want to
show I want to show some warning signs
of a disrespectful wife and just some
patterns that I've noticed that you can
see in relationships about who runs them
let's let's pull it up are you married
yeah no she's the best she's a saint and
she puts up with me and uh and she run
jokes by her do you really yeah like
should I say this is this going to you
know nowadays is always that should I
it's so weird now okay so he he admits a
couple things she's a saint and she puts
up typically men with this mindset
actually have a wife that is not a saint
and typically degrades him to make him
think that he is the problem just just
what I've noticed and typically the men
like that talk like this sort of put
their wife on a pedestal remember she
should be talking High higher of you
than you speak of her because she is
supposed to be serving you and I just
noticed that men that tend to put their
wives on pedestals often have
disrespectful wives not always I'd like
to say we always know not always the
other part that he admitted was that his
wife censors his jokes so it goes back
to what I was saying where his wife is
telling him what to say these are kind
of warning signs of a disrespectful or
dysfunctional relationship now Donald
Trump and I'm actually kind of mad cuz I
almost went to this event I almost went
but I decided I didn't want to fly
out Donald Trump went to the UFC and is
so goated he went with Tucker Carlson
and the president of the UFC they came
in and the crowd just goes wild they go
wild they're all so excited that trump
our former US president is there he's
running again and it's really an awesome
moment that you know just feels like a
little patriotic right we have Tucker
Carlson American hero UFC president
walking in Trump walking in amazing
right Bill Burr's wife decides at this
time
she will flick off the president let's
pull it
up now I I don't care about your
political party this is so disrespectful
this shows a lack of class elegance and
Grace in a woman but there is just a
lack of class and somebody that is going
to flick you off during an event but
really it's embarrassing to the guy
because this is your woman you can't
control now here we have an example of a
commenter syic Ryan Shield he just simp
simp simp simp simp simp simp simp yes
you do know wrong imagine if a guy did
this people would be like that you lack
class that's disrespectful but if a
woman does it it's cool that would be
Nia the wife of comedian Bill bur
saluting Trump during the UFC 295 in
anticipation of the F your feelings
crowd attacking her for being
disrespectful let me remind you that
Trump's entire platform is built on
attacking and disrespecting anybody that
goes after him I stand with Nia no I do
not I think there's a way that you were
supposed to conduct yourself now this
man is worth $15 million I had this
tweet and he cannot get a woman that
doesn't flick off the the president and
so I tweeted all right now this was a
little rude I I'm just saying like he's
worth $15 million and he's accepting
this level of disrespect for an
overweight woman for an overweight woman
like you at least think she would be hot
you know I mean if this is like Kiki
Palmer would have been a better pick in
this one so I also tweeted that he's
worth $14 million now I don't know I
know these things are off but let's say
it's half let's say it's 6 million a man
busts his butt to be at the top of his
career to be a top 1% earner one of the
most famous men on the planet and he
can't have a wife that behaves like what
does that say about the quality of women
we have on the market um so I I weighed
in I said $14 million can't get this
chick not to get fat and give the
president a middle finger you know women
used to have seven children and not get
this fat this is what she looked like
when they got married she's very
attractive there that is an attractive
chick and then it's like bump bump bump
this is a man's worst fear this is a
man's worst fear go back go back wait go
back imagine how we found her beautiful
BM BM
B this is a man's worst fear now
everybody comes at me when I say maybe
you shouldn't get fat in marriage
everybody comes at me it would be one
thing if he was an average guy now I
know average men deserve like like you
shouldn't get FB regardless but like
let's just say he was a broky this man's
worth $14
million Laura lomer ways in why is Bill
bur married to this isn't he a
millionaire LOL if you're a millionaire
prioritize your health and get a
personal trainer there is no excuse for
rich people to be severely obese and
unhealthy if you have money prioritize
your health yes that's my point at least
you know what I mean the poor people
maybe you know they don't have time or
whatever even the rich man cuz I know
what they'll say they'll say oh but
Pearl but Pearl he's not in the best
shape either okay I mean we can give
Elon Musk a pass for being out of shape
because he's Elon Musk he's got to
do but as a woman it's like what what
what what else do you have to do he's
taking care of everything okay Mike says
this is going to sound insane but maybe
he like loves her they're both happy you
should try it sometime Mike Mike Mike
Mike the women that you have picked I've
seen the women you've dated they have
not been fat they have not looked like
that I know it would not be your ideal
as a man to have your chick get fat
after marriage and this is what I mean
simpery this is what I call it this is
the simp effect where the men try to
Shield the women from what the men are
thinking bum bum bum reclaim your throne
says he's not in shape either they're on
the same attractiveness level honestly
he's starting to S he's starting to S
however oh oh he might be coming back
with his money and Status he definitely
doesn't know his value I almost
guarantee he cheats there it is see see
honesty honesty Mike take some notes we
like honest men now I know we might say
we hate them but we do love them
Jennifer says you know what the most
obvious thing about this pick they're
both happy
before imagine imagine you get married
and you get this amazing and then it's
like bum bum bum two kids now if you
have six kids I'll give you a pass a
little more not really but a little more
but two I mean women used to have like a
and they would just bounce back into
shape nowadays oh no no no no so guys
let me know what you think am I just the
meanie boban the evil Pearl that just
hates these women or do I maybe have a
point maybe if you're worth 14 million
dollar you should get a wife that stays
in shape and doesn't flick off the
president maybe I'm crazy I don't know
let me know in the comments what you
guys think make sure you like the video
and I'm also going to read the top
comment from last video finally somebody
who makes sense particularly about
emotional abuse by women thank you way
to go 11 like the video guys get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
I think we are going to be closing the
store this week so make sure you get
them before they are gone that's the
audacity network. store thank you for
watching I'll talk to you next time